let's continue
and let's play black against assad
all right so let's go e5 let's go e5 we
haven't got e5 very much
in the speed run and i'm not sure why
that is i i want to go e5 because i
think most people in the chat still do
play e5
so we're going to play this old school
okay so scotch
scotch defend d4
[Music]
all right um i should have played the
staff yeah i will i will play the
stafford oh i promise i'll play the
stafford next time
um okay so that's a scotch
and we take the pawn as you guys know
and here white has a choice you can go
bishop c4
that's the scotch gambit that's the
scotch gambit
now i'm trying i'm debating
how to get how to go about this okay
so i want to make a point which perhaps
will be obvious to some
but perhaps we're leaving to others when
you can sense that your opponent is
entering a line that you don't know very
much about and you're afraid
that you're going to get crushed if you
enter the main theoretical
theoretical sequence you can often make
a very quiet move
and accept a slightly worse position but
ensure that you're not going to get
blown off the board and i i want to show
you guys what that looks like
who can tell me what the main move is
here there's actually two main moves
what are they what are the moves that
are the most principled
the first is knight f6 and then after e5
we have the move d5 just to
after e5 we have d5 and the second is
bishop c5 trying to cling to the spot
i'll show you a little bit of the theory
after the game
but let's say that we wanted to avoid
the theory
we wanted to play super solid chess even
if it's a little bit passive
let's believe it should be seven let's
prevent him from going knight g5
this ensures that we're going to be able
to complete our development in peace
okay c3 now d-take c3 is a blunder this
is a very famous trap
d take c3 is a blunder
why
because of queen to d5 and if you look
at that very carefully
it turns out there's no good way of
stopping the checkmate on f7 the only
way
thing you could do is play knight h6 but
then he just takes the knight and he's
up a piece
okay so what do we do we can't take the
pawn
what are our options here well
remember when there's a situation like
this you have three main options you can
ignore
you can accept but you can you also have
sort of a fourth option which is to try
to
sacrifice back the pawn on your own
terms
sacrifice back the pawn in your own
terms resign is a fifth option
and when you want to sacrifice back the
pawn on your own terms knight f6 there
is still e5 very nasty move
let's keep the pawn up by playing d3
let's try to disallow him
from getting a dominant pawn center
by forcing him to take the pawn in this
version although he doesn't have to take
the punt
he has a very strong move queen b3 here
which he knows wow
okay so i've actually but but i but as
far as i remember
let me think no as far as i remember
this is not the move
okay as far as i remember this is not
the move but i did get
you know i got i did precisely what um i
said we wouldn't do which is get into
some theory
this is a very nasty move this is a very
nasty move
because this pawn is extremely hard to
defend it is impossible to defend
now one of the things that some of you
are familiar with is um
is a technique of meeting this move
where you go knight a5 bishop f7 king f8
and you try to disattach the queen from
the knight
and um i'm just trying to calculate that
to see if it
has any chance of working and i think it
does let's go net a5 i think it does
this is far from simple he he because he
has a very strong move in this position
let's see if he finds it
the tempting move is to go queen to d5
trying to keep the queen on the same
diagonal as the bishop
i think queen d5 is a mistake i think
queen d5 is a mistake
why is it a mistake now you guys might
look at this and say yeah it's very
similar to the evidence good connection
this knight is hanging his bishop is
defended what could possibly be wrong
with this move
but if we play c6 attack defends the
knight simultaneously
and the queen is going to be out of oh
wait
there is a move though wow no he does
have something he can do my man
it's still very very close to being lost
for him though
yep that's going out fine now i'll be
completely honest with you guys
i forgot that after night age six four
king the queen of the bishop i forgot
about the bishop
i forgot that he could take on h6 but
that's okay
that's okay we don't have to declare may
day to continue our airplane analogy all
we need to do is identify
what the big issues are the big issue is
that he's threatening
some sort of a discovered czech and star
king
what can black do here we have two
possible moves we can go knight f6 to
intercept
uh the queen and the bishop i like that
move a lot
and our other move is to well keep
bishop f6 but bishop f6 i like a lot
less because he can take the knight
so let's go knight f6 we could also have
moved the deep on and i'll show you guys
afterward yeah d6
and then covering and discovered check
with the night would have been possible
i'll show you guys some of the
complications afterward
let's go knight f6 development is the
priority knight g5
this guy is like the second coming of
tall okay
now let's try to understand what's going
on here the knight is defending the
bishop so what seems to be the most
plausible way to continue fire is on
board but i think we're going to emerge
victorious
let's be very logical here i have the
same question that you guys have let's
go h6 let's say get out of here i don't
believe you
i don't see any mates here and you got
to be very careful
very in such situations what do you need
to check for you need to look for checks
you need to make sure that there are no
weird mating sequences
this is protected this is protected you
know
um there's clearly no no immediate made
here
but you would have to be very cautious
in checking for that
okay this is russian school of chess
very concrete
e5 okay that is a really nice move
all right but it's it's not good enough
so e5 counter attacks tonight and this
position is less complicated
than it appears because we our hand is
forced here our hand is forced what do
we need to do
what do we have to do i mean obviously
we have to take his knight and then
after ef we have to take his pawn
there's no other choice we can't do
things our way
because if we had gone d6 then he would
have had the e6 square
to put one of his pieces all right now
this is
this guy is playing much stronger than
1500
but i still think that we are going to
emerge
victorious from the tactical skirmish
here he's
100 not cheating and i don't want to
hear any any accusations to that
and when i say he's playing better than
his rating that means he's good that
doesn't mean anything else
all right we can breathe we can breathe
we've got a little bit of room to
maneuver our pieces and we need to
pounce we have to pounce
um quickly or else he'll
develop his pieces and again we'll start
experiencing problems
so what does it even mean to pounds well
what moves can we make here
a lot of you guys are proposing d5
that's a good move conceptually
because you open up the bishop but is
there anything more concrete
that you may notice here remember he's
not castled yet
that's something that you should play
around with okay he's not castle what
can we do about it
well you can play queen e7 check i like
to start with this move
to see what he does if he plays bishop
e3 sky
bobbles zero move knight c4 comes in
activating the knight his best move
and a very professional move here would
be queen to e4 that's a move which
you know fifteen hundreds don't usually
make because
it's you know it involves realizing that
you treat the queens
and that pawn on d3 is a goner so the
end game the resulting endgame is going
to be equal
all right
okay
bishop e3 that's understandable
and now does the move knight c4 make
sense to everybody why can't he pin the
queen to the king well remember the
bishop is itself
pinned we have to speed up a little bit
here knight c4 it is
and uh we are beginning to overtake the
initiative
slowly but surely yeah he has to play
queen takes d3 he has no other choice he
has to take this pawn
okay castles now that is
a particularly spicy move let me see
it's not as bad as it looks
yeah so the problem is if we play d5
here it it
he plays queen takes d3 folks d5 queen
takes d3
and i'm calculating a really cool line
oh my god
wait wait wait wait guys i got to
calculate something
there's there's genuinely complex line
there that i'm trying to work
work through and i think it works for us
it's not it's not beautiful but it's
it's cool it's
it's cool in a complex sense we start
with d5 this looks like a blunder
we start with d5 we start with d5
okay this move is understandable we
activate the bishop but it may seem like
a mistake we are essentially forcing him
to take the pawn
okay now what's her idea is it to take
the pawn on b2 no uh he doesn't take the
pawn he makes a blunder
i'll show you guys afterward this is a
blunder why
what should he be looking for well you
should immediately spot the bishop and
the queen they're on
knights distance apart and of course
the simple knight e5 results in a fork
against the queen of the bishop
and he is starting to burn
daddy thank you
yeah this is basically gg and i've i've
mentioned this many times before
the notion that sometimes these players
are incredibly good in the opening they
play a bunch of good tactical moves but
if you just keep your composure
they will lose their cool they'll lose
their
lose their composure before you lose
yours and you just gotta outlast them
sometimes in the calculation
okay now how should we go about winning
this as quickly as possible
we need to realize what our assets are
our first asset is that we're up a piece
that's great
our second asset is that we have the age
file how can we exploit it well we can
explain it
in a variety of ways perhaps some of you
are indicating queenie five that's a
lovely move
that's a lovely move because you're
inducing
one of several weaknesses either h3 or
g3 and this is a great example of not
needing a pawn storm
we are still attacking we don't need a
pawn storm why because we already have
the open file served to us
so we don't need to push this g pod
forward in fact that would be very
counterproductive
f4 all right
what should we take with what seems more
natural
so it seems more natural more simple to
take with a pawn well sorry stick with
the knight
take with the knight uh just to just to
uh force another trade perhaps get rid
of his bishop
and uh this is totally winning we're up
a piece we have
this square for our queen in case we
want to trade queens that's very
possible as well
um and in fact if he goes knight to d2
i propose that the simplest if you're in
time pressure
and you want to guarantee win don't well
f3 he goes knight takes after we have
three knight takes f3 and he defends the
pawn on h2 thank you gary
thank you so much gary raiding just when
we needed 113 coming over
i know it's lame but let's go for the
queen trade i know it's lame but if you
have a minute and a half
we can go for the queen trade because
you know that you can play very fast
and relatively accurately in the
resulting end game
all right thank you so much gary hope
hope you had a great stream welcome guys
tail end of my speedrun
hope you guys stick around um we have
some instructive analyzing to do this
was a really cool game
now what should how should we
coordinate our pieces what are the
priorities here
what is the top priority and how should
we go about
getting this priority accomplished
yeah so we need to develop we need to
develop in order to defend this pawn
now if we play bishop g4 there is a bit
of an issue with that move who can spot
that issue
and i'm gonna play it anyway i'm gonna
play it anyway because there's a
follow-up to this yeah that's the issue
but we can strike first we can go e2 and
say no no no you're attacking the bishop
we're attacking the rook
okay he's just going to take on g4
that's a bit boring and now we are up a
rook
now the simplest is to say yeah you can
click king e7
defend the bishop king e7 don't let him
win him in the pawn
he's probably gonna okay knight e3 yeah
now all we need to do is just bring our
rook centralize the king bring the rooks
to the open files alternatively
as you're thinking you need to be
identifying the area of the board
where you're going to create a past pawn
because that's going to be the way that
you win the game ultimately
what i'm what i'm seeing is these two
pawns i'm saying okay
so when the time is right i'm going to
play c5 and d4 not yet
first i'm going to bring the rooks in
and that allows me to play fast i've
already charted out
exactly what i'm going to do in the
order in which i'm going to do it
so can you play t4 not quite because
then he plays knight takes f6 the guy is
very clever
so let's patiently bring the king up and
defend the pawn
okay now we can do a bunch of different
things the simplest is to go for the
rook trade that's
a sub priority here how does this move
allow us to go for the rook trade well
as you guys can see
we are preparing rookie one clinical
simple again allows you to play fast
we're going to pre-move
i'm not going to pre-move we don't need
to
this is plenty of time plenty of time to
win an end game like this
because now you can start pushing the
pawn the only thing you need to be
watching for here are forks forex forks
forks
don't get forked make sure the easiest
way of doing this
positioning your king in your rook like
this is not a good idea from that
perspective
because if the knight were to appear on
e6 here you would be in trouble
how should we play what should we how
what is the final step in the chain
what is the final step in the chain what
should we do
we should go rookie and rookie three
beautiful and then that wins the game
because that dislodges the knight he has
to go here
we take the knight we will draw the rook
and then we promote to a queen
if he doesn't do it and we take the
knight and we promote the pawn anyway
yeah guys you don't have to worry about
the clock i
i'm in control of the situation i'm in
complete and total control of the
situation i will not let you down
this is the current the unit of time
when i look at this and i see 11 seconds
and i don't mean to be
cocky it but it it really is an eternity
it's an eternity because it's just
you know if you had three seconds okay
we'd be having a conversation
i'm a professional ogm that's exactly
right
all right you see and with some time to
spam
okay um
just to make sure everybody's at ease
but that was much simpler than it seemed
this is just a forced mate
that was an elegant finish though i like
these i like this kind of mate bishop
covers these squares
broke defense queen uncovers those
squares rookie one was i made earlier
yup
um no i don't think so ricky when he
moves his king
okay
so let's analyze and then we'll wrap up
he played very well you know
congratulations
he played an incredibly good game
now again i want to make very clear that
from my perspective when i compliment
these players if i suspected somebody of
cheating i would be very straight and i
would say i think this guy's
might be cheating and then we'd
investigate the game
if i'm just saying that he's playing
above his rating or he's playing really
really well i'm not implying anything
you shouldn't infer anything um
and you also need to understand you
shouldn't be
somebody who goes around every time you
lose a game where you feel like it was a
one-sided game
i know some people like this they
immediately assume their opponent is
cheating
this guy's shooting that guy drinking
there is a big cheating problem there's
a lot of people who are cheating
but most people are not and um
it's important to build up that
atmosphere where
if you suspect your opponent of cheating
the first thing you need to do
is you need to go to the analysis tab
okay
this is a bit of a detour but i and i
don't mean to moralize but this is a
more practical thing
let's say that you have the wrong you
have a bad sense in your mouth you have
a bad taste in your mouth
that game was too clean all right you go
to the analysis tab
and you walk through the game with an
engine that's that's all you need to do
and that'll give you a very good sense
of whether or not your opponent
you have any leg to stand on even this
doesn't tell you whether your opponent
cheated or not
it tells you whether you have any kind
of a leg to stand on let me just
expand all of this the accuracy is a
good indicator all right this is very
misunderstood
if you played a short game that's 10
moves long disregard the accuracy the
accuracy is
only helpful for longer games to give
you a general sense
anything over 90 is pretty really good
if you're 16 1700 really anything below
around 2200 90s games are pretty
uncommon
but again 99 is something a lot of
people get at least
once let's say a month you will if you
play enough games
have a perfect game you'll have a game
where you almost didn't make any
mistakes
um and then you can just run through the
game with an engine all right that's all
you want to do
you run through the game with an engine
and
you kind of check all right well was
this move that i thought was suspicious
was this a
wait what's uh sorry you know was this a
suspicious move
you sort of see okay this was good but
this was inaccurate
you know this was best he played well
but this was a mistake so clearly the
guy is human and then he makes a very
big mistake
castles um
when you get suspicious is when it's
like every move
seems to be very accurate or it's in the
top two or three moves in the computer a
lot of cheaters
they will not make the top computer move
they will make the second or the third
move a lot of the time to throw you off
another thing which is frequently
misunderstood if i express my suspicions
of somebody
the response maybe but on move 27
your opponent made a mistake so he can't
be cheating that that
doesn't disqualify somebody from
accusations
you some cheaters will throw in a
mistake or two so it's much more
complicated than that
but you could use the analysis feature
to give yourself a good sense of
whether or not you have a case if you
have a case click the report button you
don't need to make a big fuss of it
chess.com does investigate all of the
good faith reports
yeah brilliant moves are no brilliant
moves are definitely
something to feel to feel good about
without a doubt okay
um
time on moves is also a great indication
through the classic three seconds per
move kind of thing
all right so also check their previous
game history and stuff like that so
knight f6
is the main move and after e5 d5 you get
the main line theory of the scotch
gambit
i have a student who plays the scotch
gamut i i think it's a phenomenal
opening for white
very dangerous and up until gm level
people don't know what to do even i
am rusty on the theory here and
after bishop b5 the main line goes 94
now you get this weird kind of structure
where white drives the spawn into e5
and it's a super interesting line i
would highly recommend that if you're
tactical
you want something that's relatively
easy to learn you investigate the scotch
gambit
all right the other move is bishop c5
and white goes c3 again
and after d takes e3 there is a
common misconception not too often
there's a common misconception
where people think windy 5 wins a piece
but remember forks
need to be checked against move which
may defend both at the same time
i would call this almost a defensive
fork a defensive fork is a move that
defends against a fork
in the same way that a fork works you
defend rather than attacking both pieces
at the same time
you defend both pieces at the same time
so in this position queen d5 is the
right idea you don't want to abandon the
idea
but when you have a two move sequence
right you want to go here and here
what do you need to do before you
abandon the idea you need to check what
happens if you switch
up the move order switch up the move
order
boom first now boom and
yes you don't win a piece but guess what
you've equalized the material
and black's king is going to be
permanently in trouble
so this is not good so that's why we
decided to go bishop b7 frankly i forgot
about c3 being a move
c3 is a super nasty move in contrast to
the bishop being on c5
the bishop being only seven of course
doesn't allow the queen to get out
black is losing knight h6 bishop takes
h6
okay so we played d3 trying to
throw the spawn out on our own terms you
will also see this in the smith more and
the smith mora
you can play d3 in this position that's
a pretty good line
um which you know sort of gives the game
more positional contours
um this is called the sky the the scotch
gambit but
uh queen b3 is excellent going after the
pawn
you went after the pawn knight a5
is a super common response to this and
now things heat up bishop takes f7 king
f8 queen to d5
frankly i expected him to go queen to a4
superiors think about the prime
now remember this method of defending
against
uh the situation you don't have to keep
the queen on the same diagonal you can
shift the queen over and attack a piece
that's undefended
if you want to save your bishop or not
give up a piece
if black defends the knight well then
the bishop is free to go back
take the bishop then white takes the
knight and you know material is equal
and
black's king is weak so this would have
been a good move
but this i thought was losing due to c6
now the knight is defended
and i completely missed that after
knight h6 you can just take the knight
see i
hallucinate too this happens you just
hallucinate
i'm honestly not sure how overly move is
defined guys i don't know what the
formula is
i would imagine that it has something to
do
with the sort of second best move
not being nearly as good but i don't i
really don't know i i don't check my
games for brilliant moves so i can't
help you too much i can i guess i can
investigate it a little bit yeah so i i
was tripping here i hallucinated
and obviously if you if you play g6
then bishop takes g6 happens and black
is busted
if you go d5 then the bishop can step
back to e6
so this queen is amazingly well
protected so instead of going d5 and
attacking the queen we intercept
the mechanism by bringing the knight out
to f6
all right hard to find yeah stuff like
that knight g5
h6 get out of here and another great
move e5 now at this point he already
made a big mistake i think that he
still in this position i think knight g5
was a big mistake
i think that he should have dropped the
bishop back to b3
and dropped the queen back and just
brought all his pieces back although
here we still have
these passers so i would imagine then
that queen a4
is indeed guys the best move here queen
a4 would have been the best way for to
an advantage after queen d5
he gets into this path of no return
where his pieces
bite off more than they can show okay so
e5
counter attacking the knight takes takes
takes
please ask any questions you have here
because i know a lot is going on
so now if we count up the pawns he's got
six puns we have
seven puns we're up a pawn which is
which is good but more importantly his
king all of a sudden is the one that's
unsafe
and we're seeing we're doing fine
okay so bishop g6 what if e5 will move
earlier so if you go if you went e5 here
yeah probably he should have done that
honestly but it's a similar thing takes
takes takes and we're fine
um okay so knight g5 h6
why not take his bishop because then he
takes our bishop with a discovered check
and we have to take with the king and
then his bishop comes out pinning our
queen
so that's unfortunately not sufficient
and now we decided to give this check on
e7 testing the waters
and so as i explained queen e4 in my
eyes would be a brilliant move
for a 1 500 this would be a brilliant
move one of the factors that
in my informal definition goes into a
blue move is a move that avoids a
tempting alternative there was a
tempting alternative
you didn't play it you understood why it
was wrong instead you played the deep
move
thank you nathaniel for the prime queen
e4
um this move is good because it
essentially forces the queen trade black
has no choice
don't go here because of mate and
oh wow that's really cool that the
engines don't see initially so it's it
has to do with
the depth yeah and you know you get an
equal end game black has doubled pawns
but you got the h file
you got a nice little pawn wedge here so
it's just a game
um but instead he goes bishop e3 which
allows us to bring the knight into the
game with knight c4
and now white is in big trouble he
accentuates this after castles
and i just have one really cool line to
show you
now what should white have done here he
should have taken and accepted a bad
position but probably a playable
position after queen takes d3
now one thing that i want to tell you
what should black do and not do here
black is a couple of good moves what
move should be avoided and why
we can explain that
and i'll show you guys something very
cool this is not
the main cool thing a lot of people here
it looks tempting but you got to
prioritize development
and as a cautionary tale after queen e2
yeah if you try to be cute
no no it doesn't work anyway what i
wanted to show you was the idea of
bishop c5
which wins the game because of this mate
idea but black could go knight a4 here
and get away with this by the hair on
his chinny chin chin
because bishop c5 knight takes c5 but
still i wouldn't bother with this i
wouldn't bother
i would probably just go d5 prioritize
development
that is almost always more important now
the funny thing is
if he takes on d3 here it transposes
potentially
to the position after d5 castles this
would have been the same position
as in the game okay
so what the heck would we have done if
he would have taken on d3
well the first move is the same one that
we played in the game it's 95.
okay this is a fork but it doesn't seem
like a very
effective fork because he can tuck his
queen on c2
but now we take the bishop and what i
was thinking about was the move here
this is the crucial move yeah
well you deserve a sub dark at the top
you go queen to e5 threatening checkmate
and if he defends against mate
this combination of combination is
permeating and so on and on bishop f5
yeah
bishop f5 and the queen is trapped
there's also a check here to factor in
bishop c5
but it doesn't do anything king g8 white
has only one way i think
to extend the game white has only one
way to extend the game what is it
what is it
it's it's um it's not bishop d4 there's
a matrix guys
it's f4 f4 is a way to stave off the
main
so that the queen can evacuate you also
have this move bishop to d4
um and i was calculating this i wasn't
exactly sure what we would have done
here
but at the very least the very least
black can probably go bishop f5 and get
a nice position
so i i wasn't sure i still wanted to do
this because
it's a very cool idea this concept of
threatening checkmate and
using the threat as a vehicle to set up
another tactic such as a queen trap
remember that
you know this it's a form of tunnel
vision to think only in one direction
either ah
you want to mate them on the h file or
you want to trap the queen you can
combine
these things thank you so queen f3 makes
our job easy 95 and we win the queen we
win the piece rather
and here we decide to play it very
simple and trade queens
the rest is incredibly um incredibly
straightforward thank you third elect
for the prime
any questions about this game i feel
like people are still discussing the
brilliant move you can you can do your
own research on that guys
i'm not a specialist so
you're welcome
and again i want to thank everybody for
uh for the
thank you skye well what if bishop f5
instead of queen e3
um well yeah bishop f5 would be the move
i would play
in in a real game in my game but after
queen f3
the funny thing is if you let his rook
come to e1
our king is not exactly out of the wood
so i wouldn't i wouldn't risk it i would
this is we're up a piece and two pawns
and that's a huge material advantage so
i think a queen trade is is is
definitely the simplest i i usually tell
my students
that that being up a piece is the
threshold
when trading queens is almost always a
safe path to victory
if you're up a pawn or two pawns unless
you can transition into a pawn end game
you shouldn't go out of your way to try
to trade queens if you're up a piece or
more and you're down on time
you can consider a queen that doesn't
mean you have to seek out a queen trade
if if you're attacking but what i mean
is to say
queen trades can be a very effective way
to win when you're up a piece or more
hopefully you found that instructive
thank you everybody for
the incredible support particularly
today
so uh this helps me tremendously in
keeping the late night grind going i
know i've been playing a lot of blitz
lately and
sort of grinding my own writing but
we're going to keep this going more
stuff on the horizon
yeah so thank you guys very very much
the community is always always
phenomenal and uh uh take care of you
guys stay safe